wait if you have a problem figuring out  whether you're for me or trump then you  ain't black  [Music]  there's the first time  and i i guess i shouldn't apologize but  i do apologize for the fact the united  states uh  the last administration pulled out of  the paris courts and put us sort of  behind  people  you have a problem figuring out whether  you're for me or trump and you ain't  black now i didn't want to show you the  entire clip of him falling asleep  because it's long it's like nine minutes  he got into rem sleeping he was dreaming  yeah it's really  it's like it was an inception night for  him yeah i mean he was giving the hair a  run for his money well just getting  passed by turtles  growing up with a still-skinned beard  slow and steady wins the race no i think  for the former vice presidents slow and  uh uh slow slow slow yeah slow slow  oh no  yes  yes oh wait i mean he's vulnerable